starting this hour off is alica and
hawaii i alika how are you good how are
you sir
better than I deserve what's up um I
just had a quick question asked you um
recently I got about to the exact 7
bombshells dropped on me um in the form
of credit card debts that I was not
aware of and I'm wondering if I should
that kind of high interest rate so I'm
wondering if I should consolidate them
to a 15 year where the rate will be
manageable and then I could attack it
from there without the home the minimum
payments being so high every month I'm
sorry how does credit card debt 7
bombshells occur help me with this okay
so I've been married for 16 years um
when my wife and I got together she took
over the finances which was great
because I had terrible credit so we were
able to buy a house back in like 2001
then back then our philosophy was we
don't spend any more than we can pay off
every month and we did that you know for
the food throughout the beginning of our
marriage and I kind of um I stopped
paying attention to the finances and let
her take care of it and the other day I
opened up a a credit card statement
expecting it to be maybe in a thousand
or 2,000 range it was nineteen thousand
and how was our just the first started
digging and found a total of seven other
credit cards with a total of and home
equity line for a total of ninety
thousand that I didn't even know about
Wow
that's a pretty serious gut-punch yeah
the $19 guessing dinner that night was a
little guessing dinner that night was a
little stressful uh yeah well I mean
we've got two beautiful kids and we
didn't want to stress them too much with
with our adult situations so dinner
wasn't so bad I mean she feels terrible
she's really good at paying things on
time no she's not but um she sucks at
her yeah she's really good at hiding it
yeah yeah so why was she hiding it why
didn't she tell you um I've been asking
myself that question I would ask her
yeah I've asked her she has been scared
to tell me she said I think we've been
kind of living the dream and she didn't
she didn't want to I mean I knew in the
back of my head it wasn't really adding
up but I didn't know is that's kind of
like opening a credit card statement I
didn't know is this bad I guess had been
happening for a long time
what's your household income about a
hundred one hundred and thirty thousand
okay all right and how old are your kids
I got uh 21 15 and 11 okay are you guys
in a good church by chance no okay I
want you to seek out a good Christian
marriage counselor and the two of you go
see them immediately please let me tell
you the statistics around discovering
$90,000 worth of deception and a divorce
following our very high you you have
been gut-punched almost in the same way
as if she's had an affair the breach of
trust is very similar it's obviously
different tactical actions but the
breach of trust of her level of
deception and your level of lack of
involvement that allowed that deception
to occur the two of you both have some
things to talk through
you are now involved in the money every
month for the rest of your life do you
understand her never again do you turn
this over it's not because it's because
the way you guys were doing it doesn't
work obviously and both people in the
house need to be involved in the budget
I don't mind if she executed the budget
after the two of you agreed to it but
you both need to carry the weight of the
decisions because she does not have the
ability to tell you or your family know
her and she consequently ran up these
bills because she wasn't good at
budgeting she wasn't good at handling
this she wasn't good at selling people
no she wasn't good at managing the big
decisions of the household by herself
and that's where all this came from and
so all she all she did was the best she
could do but it wasn't good and so she
gets to work with you both of you
together you don't take it over and she
gets shut out now you get to work
together for the rest of your life and
you sit down with a marriage counselor
and you talk through how this made you
feel that your wife has lied to you for
$90,000 worth because a normal human
being is both hurt and pissed off when
that occurs and if you're not both of
those things right now you're not normal
I'm pretty okay and she's pretty
condemned and ashamed and beat down and
has a lot of Tears if she's normal now
that are lies in deception yeah a lot of
crying usually when the the dam breaks
that's what happens because she's been
carrying the weight of this lie and high
takes a lot of energy to lie at this
level and it's and so you guys have got
to work through that stuff and this
could be the best thing that ever
happens to your family it could be the
best thing that ever happens to your
relationship or it will cause it all to
come to an end suddenly and you won't
even realize where it came from if you
don't go deal with it so sit down with a
counselor for God's sakes you need
marriage counseling okay and then I'm
going to put you guys in financial peace
for a year and that includes going to
the class and both of you are going to
go to the
class and both of you are going to get
on a budget and both of you are going to
start telling your family know about
$90,000 worth of no and no you don't
need to refinance your way out of this
the interest rate is not your problem
your problem is you guys have been
spending like you were in Congress right
and you guys got to quit spending you
make enough money
Hawaii's expensive to live but you make
enough money and here's the deal let's
do some quick math okay if we pay off
forty five thousand dollars a year
you're done in two years so you're
probably done in about three years okay
thirty thousand a year for three years
and you're done and you can do that with
what you make but your family is going
to be on beans and rice rice and beans
we're not going to the inside not gonna
see the inside of a restaurant unless
we're working there and vacation is
going to be in your backyard there's you
got to clean it you got to roll your
sleeves up and bust this thing in the
nose and turn it around so I'll walk
with you brother
but you do the things I'm telling you to
do or you're in a danger zone get with a
marriage counselor and get in this
financial peace class and I'll pay for
the classes free to you guys I want to
be part of your healing not part of your
problem